We're now into version two of UML. Which has as a total 14 different kinds
of diagrams. We're going to go over those quickly here but in the course we're
not going to be using all of them. We're going to concentrate on just three or
four of them. And we'll have special lessons devoted to those but I wanted you
to at least be aware of the different kinds of diagrams that are there.
That said, on a particular project, you're unlikely to use all the diagrams.
You're going to use the ones appropriate to the particular project.
In particular, determine what is the trickiest part of the project and
use the diagram that helps you best understand that tricky part.
The two main categories of diagrams are structural and behavioral.
Structural diagrams give you the pieces of the system that are always there and
the relationships among them. Behavioral diagrams on the other hand,
are concerned with the executions of the system. And the particular diagram
may only convey one execution. That is, you may have to have multiple sequence
diagrams in order to get a good feel for all of the behaviors of the system